your money talk to Brian no sorry yeah I
brian is Boris Johnson here and you've
asked me what motivates me let me tell
you I've just met Jamie Dimon he was
looking for here for the bathroom he
said we were able to help him out there
but he said that London was the biggest
financial capital in Europe and had her
mentor what I want to do is to get
everybody here to understand London is
the greatest financial city in the world
I'm not just in Europe and that it is
the best big city on earth to come live
in and invest in and if I can persuade
some of the world leaders here in Davos
of that eternal truth then my time here
were to be wasted